Hay un campo en el China todavía es incapaz
de competir con Estados Unidos.
Un campo donde Estados Unidos sigue siendo
el líder mundial indiscutible: ni China,
ni Japón ni ningún país europeo se le acercan.
Me refiero a la universidad.
Da igual el ranking que miréis... en todos
ellos, las universidades estadounidenses ocupan
casi todos los primeros puestos.
Tener un título de YALE, STANDFORD o el MIT
parece una pasarela segura para los mejores
trabajos.
Muchos pensaréis que en Estados Unidos están
orgullosísimos de sus universidades.
Que todos los estudiantes van felices al campus
sabiendo que les espera un futuro brillante.
SIn embargo, atentos a esta noticia.
Los estudiantes protestan por las subidas
del precio de las matrículas mientras las
universidades continúan dando clases online
Y diréis ¿Pero por qué protestan los estudiantes?
¿Tiene algo que ver con el coronavirus?
¿Tantas ganas tienen de volver a las clases
presenciales?
Pues nada de eso.
Las universidades estadounidenses pueden ser
fantásticas pero tienen un problema: el precio
de la matrícula.
En las últimas décadas, el precio de la
Universidad en Estados Unidos se ha disparado.
La matrícula cuesta hoy día el triple que
hace 30 años.
Para que os hagáis una idea, estudiar en
HARVARD o en YALE puede costar más de 50.000
dólares de matrícula.
Y diréis ¿Cómo se paga todo eso?
Seguro que muchos ya sabéis la respuesta.
Sobretodo los que veáis este vídeo desde
Estados Unidos: con deuda.
En este país, 2 de cada 3 estudiantes está
en deuda para pagar su matrícula.
Cuando acaban sus estudios, la media de lo
que deben es de 29.000 dólares.
Repito, la media de lo que deben.
Gastarse se han gastado mucho más.
La deuda estudiantil acumulada por 45 millones
de estadounidenses se ha disparado al billón
y medio de dólares.
Y sí, decimos billones en castellano: en
inglés sería trillions.
Y más de uno os preguntaréis, ¿es mucho?
¿Es poco?
Bueno, la verdad es que es una pasta.
Es más que el PIB de un país como España.
O en otras palabras: solo hay 12 países que
conseguirían producir en un año “sin coronavirus”
lo suficiente para saldar la deuda acumulada
por los universitarios de Estados Unidos.
Todo esto es especialmente doloroso cuando
lo comparamos con Europa, donde estudiar en
la universidad sale casi gratis para el estudiante.
De hecho, el problema con el precio de la
universidad es toda una prioridad política.
Si no hubiera sido por el coronavirus, se
habría hablado largo y tendido de esto durante
las elecciones presidenciales de 2020.
De hecho, algunos candidatos demócratas como
Bernie Sanders presentaban propuestas como
esta.
El senador estadounidense Bernie Sanders propone
un proyecto de ley para una matrícula universitaria
gratis y el fin de la deuda estudiantil
Así que la pregunta es ¿Por qué la universidad
es tan cara en Estados Unidos?
¿Cuáles son las diferencias entre el modelo
universitario de Estados Unidos y el europeo?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas, pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
EL CAMINO HACIA LA CLASE MEDIA
Hasta la segunda guerra mundial, la universidad
estaba reservada únicamente a las élites.
Pero todo cambió durante la guerra.
El presidente Roosevelt quería que sus soldados
tuvieran un futuro mejor tras arriesgar su
vida en Europa o en el Pacífico.
Así que dos semanas después del Desembarco
de Normandía aprobó la “Ley de reincorporación
de soldados”.
(((EN INGLÉS Servicemen's Readjustment Act)))
Si a lo que supuso esta ley le sumamos la
prosperidad que hubo tras la guerra, nos encontramos
con que Estados Unidos se convirtió en el
primer país del mundo en el que las clases
medias fueron a la universidad.
Es la cristalización del sueño americano:
poder mandar a tus hijos a la universidad.
“El camino más seguro hacia la clase media:
alguna forma de educación superior”
Hasta ahora cada generación ha vivido mejor
que la de sus padres.
Hay cosas que se han vuelto muy asequibles:
la tecnología, viajar, ver VisualPolitik...
Pero también es verdad que hay dos cosas
importantes que se están encareciendo: la
vivienda y la universidad.
¿Por qué la matrícula se ha disparado a
precios prohibitivos?
La ley de la oferta y la demanda da una buena
explicación: el número de estudiantes universitarios
en Estados Unidos se ha duplicado en 50 años.
No sólo hablamos de ciudadanos estadounidenses
sino también de extranjeros.
Más de un millón de personas de todo el
mundo viajan cada a año a estudiar en Estados
Unidos.
Y ahora estaréis pensando: ¿pero hay tantos
jóvenes de todo el mundo dispuestos a gastarse
una pasta con tal de no perderse las míticas
fiestas universitarias?
Pues aunque no descarto el factor American
Pie, creo que hay otros motivos para explicar
el atractivo de la universidad americana.
Escuelas de Estados Unidos ocupan 8 de los
10 puestos principales en la lista de US News
de las mejores universidades del mundo en
Sí, ya sé lo que me vais a decir: guau Fonseca,
un ranking hecho en Estados Unidos que dice:
“hey tíos, somos los mejores”… vaale,
aquí tenéis el ranking de la Universidad
de Shanghái.
Como podéis ver con las banderitas, la conclusión
es obvia: da igual el ranking que cojas: las
universidades estadounidenses son las más
prestigiosas del mundo.
Y ya sé lo que os estaréis preguntando ¿Cómo
se hacen estos rankings?
¿De verdad se puede medir lo bien que enseña
un profesor?
¿Miden el número de aprobados?
Pues atentos, porque aquí llega el auténtico
“quid” de la cuestión.
Medir la calidad de un profesor dando clase
es difícil.
Lo que sí podemos medir es su calidad como
investigador: sus publicaciones en revistas,
la cantidad de veces que le han citado, etc...
Así que ¿Qué tienes que hacer si quieres
que tu universidad esté arriba en el ranking?
Dinero: dinero para tener los mejores laboratorios
pero, sobretodo, para tener los mejores investigadores.
Para que os hagáis una idea, la mitad de
los gastos de una universidad como Harvard
se van pagar al personal.
Por hacer una comparación: un profesor de
universidad en España, en el mejor de los
casos, puede ganar unos 80,000 dólares al
año.
En Harvard, la media ronda los 200,000 dólares.
Y diréis ¿Pero cómo se paga todo esto?
¿De dónde viene el dinero?
Pues atentos a esta gráfica.
“¿Quién paga la universidad en EEUU?
Ingresos de la Universidad de Harvard, 2019
“Matrícula: 22%
Ayudas a la investigación: 17%
Donaciones privadas: 43%
Otros: 18%”
Como podéis ver se paga con donaciones millonarias
de antiguos alumnos, fondos públicos que
fundamentalmente premian la investigación,
y las matrículas de los estudiantes.
Al final los estadounidenses gastan un 2,7%
de su PIB a la educación universitaria.
Muy por encima de la media de la OCDE, que
es del 1,6%.
¿Qué significa todo esto?
Pues que buena parte de esta carrera tecnológica
la están financiando los estudiantes.
Y esa no es la única mala noticia para los
alumnos.
ESTUDIO: La mitad de los empleadores no creen
que la universidad prepare a los estudiantes
para el trabajo
Lo que está claro es que, en el modelo universitario
de Estados Unidos, todos los profesores están
más preocupados en investigar que en dar
clase porque la investigación es lo que les
da prestigio y no la docencia.
Mientras tanto, ¿En Europa qué es lo que
pasa?
Ahora lo vemos.
EL MODELO EUROPEO
La principal diferencia entre el modelo universitario
de Estados Unidos y el europeo es que las
mejores universidades de Europa son públicas.
Pero cuando decimos públicas es una forma
de decir que la matrícula es… como decirlo,
no gratis, pero sí un regalo comparado con
las públicas de Estados Unidos.
Porque hay universidades públicas en Estados
Unidos, sí.
Son las llamadas universidades estatales.
Pero la diferencia de precios es enorme: el
precio medio más bajo de una universidad
estatal es de más de 8.000 dólares.
Sin embargo, en España, la matrícula más
cara en universidad pública de Cataluña
se sitúa en 2.800 dólares.
Y quiero recalcar que he comparado lo más
barato con lo más caro.
Estas diferencias obedecen fundamentalmente
a dos cuestiones.
La primera es que en Europa el Estado cubre
aproximadamente un 80% de lo que cuesta cada
año en la universidad pública.
Y lo hace para todos sus alumnos, con independencia
de que vengan de familias ricas o pobres.
La segunda cuestión es que no hay tanto afán
por investigar.
Se da mucha más importancia a la docencia.
Pero incluso las universidades privadas europeas
son mucho más baratas que las estadounidenses.
El precio medio de la matrícula en Harvard,
Yale o el MIT es de 50.000 dólares.
Mientras que la matrícula más cara en la
Universidad de Navarra, en España, ronda
los 18.000 dólares.
¿Cuál es la ventaja del modelo europeo?
Pues que no es habitual ver a gente endeuda
para pagar la universidad.
(Y alguno me dirá “pues yo estoy endeudado!!”
Por supuesto que hay casos, pero no es lo
normal) Ahora bien ¿Qué sacrifica Europa
al tener universidades tan baratas?
Pues que la universidad no investiga.
Y como no investiga, es poco atractiva.
Para ver universidades de la Unión Europea
en los rankings globales tienes que bajar
al puesto 26 para encontrar la primera universidad
danesa, al 37 para ver una francesa, al 47
para ver una alemana… Para ver una española
o una italiana tenemos que irnos a más allá
del 150.
Claro, cuando uno ve donde están las universidades
de Europa en estos rankings globales, entiendes
por qué la Comisión Europea tiene este tipo
de preocupaciones:
La Unión Europea prepara un competidor europeo
para Google con nuevos datos y propuestas
de inteligencia artificial
Los proyectos de investigación son muy pobres,
con pocos fondos.
Europa tiene un modelo de universidad muy
social, asequible, pero con estos mimbres
no se hace un gigante tecnológico tipo Facebook.
Lo ideal sería tener una universidad que
investigue más pero que siga estando al alcance
de cualquier bolsillo.
¿Qué modelo se está imponiendo en el mundo?
Y lo que es más importante ¿Es posible tener
lo mejor de ambos modelos?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
DOS MODELOS EN LUCHA
Ya sé lo que muchos os estaréis preguntando
en este momento ¿De verdad merece la pena
gastarse tanto dinero en una universidad?
¿De verdad estudiar en la universidad es
garantía de tener un buen trabajo el día
de mañana?
Si miramos los datos, la respuesta que encontramos
es que... depende.
De entrada, el 30% de los estudiantes abandonan
la universidad antes de terminarla.
Eso significa que han pagado los primeros
años de matrícula para nada.
Claramente, en este caso, gastar tanto dinero
ha sido una mala inversión.
Pero ¿Qué pasa con los que las terminan?
Pues depende del título y de la universidad.
No gana lo mismo un ingeniero en telecomunicaciones
que un licenciado en historia del arte.
Y no gana lo mismo un graduado de Yale que
uno de la Universidad de Nevada.
El sueldo medio 10 años después de conseguir
un título en Harvard se sitúa entre los
80.000/90.000 dólares.
Sin embargo, en otras universidades privadas,
el sueldo medio está alrededor de los 40.000
dólares.
Es decir, que es más o menos lo mismo que
ganarías si estudiaras en una universidad
estatal, que es más barata.
En otras palabras: elegir universidad no sólo
implica que muchos estudiantes se endeudan.
También implica un riesgo enorme.
Dependiendo de la universidad que elijas,
tendrás un trabajo u otro.
Así que ¿Qué proponen los políticos como
Bernie Sanders para solucionar este problema?
Pues muy sencillo: gasto público.
Nuestra propuesta, que cuesta 2,2 billones
en 10 años, será pagada en su totalidad
por un impuesto sobre la especulación de
Wall Street
En otras palabras, Bernie Sanders quiere que
el estado pague todas las matrículas nuevas
y todas las deudas de estudiantes.
Hablamos de esos 2,2 billones de dólares
en 10 años.
Y, a partir de ahí, la Casa Blanca tendría
que pagar otros 48.000 millones de dólares
anuales para pagar las nuevas matrículas.
Para que os hagáis una idea, hablaríamos
del coste de organizar tres juegos olímpicos...
¡Año tras año!
Como os podéis imaginar, en un momento donde
Estados Unidos ya está gastando a manos llenas
por las ayudas del coronavirus, no parece
que vayan a poder gastar aún más en las
universidades.
Y diréis ¿Entonces, no hay ninguna ayuda
pública para las universidades?
Pues sí, sí que las hay.
Lo que pasa es que no son ayudas directas
sino préstamos del Estado a intereses muy
bajos.
Para que os hagáis una idea, el 92% de toda
esa deuda estudiantil de la que os hemos hablado
son préstamos de Washington.
Por ejemplo, una de las fórmulas más usadas
es lo que llaman el PAYE (pay as you earn).
Cuando terminas la universidad, devuelves
el préstamo al Washington dándole el 10%
de lo que ganas en tu salario.
Si terminas de pagar tu deuda, genial para
todos.
Ahora, si no te va bien en la vida y no has
podido devolver la deuda en 20 años, el Estado
te perdona el resto.
A este tipo de programas están acogidos 8
millones de estadounidenses.
Y diréis ¡Problema resuelto!
¿De qué se quejan entonces?
Pues porque precisamente, este tipo de ayudas
han contribuido a disparar aún más los costes
de matrícula.
Como los estudiantes pueden pedir créditos
para pagarlos, las universidades no dudan
en pedir cantidades astronómicas por la matrícula.
En otras palabras: que parece que no hay una
solución perfecta a este problema.
Sin embargo, sí hay algo que podemos decir:
si hay un modelo que se está imponiendo en
el mundo... ese es el de Estadus Unidos.
Por ejemplo, Arabia Saudita ha invertido unos
10.000 millones de dólares en crear una universidad
siguiendo el modelo estadounidense.
Cuando Qatar quiere impulsar su sistema universitario,
no es que copien el modelo estadounidense,
es que hacen directamente esto:
Las universidades estadounidenses están construyendo
un oasis académico en la Ciudad de la Educación
de Qatar
Georgetown y Northwestern son algunas de estas
universidades que tienen su propia sede en
Qatar.
Yale sede en Singapur.
La Universidad de Nueva York en Shanghai y
Abu Dhabi.
En otras palabras, parece que el mundo prefiere
matrículas caras a cambio de liderar en investigación.
Seamos claros: Silicon Valley no existiría
si no fuera por la universidad de Standford.
Y lo mismo ocurre en muchas otras áreas:
si Estados Unidos es líder en tantas tecnologías
se debe, en buena medida, a que han sido capaces
de financiar investigación científica.
Y esto es gracias a las universidades.
En otras palabras: la universidad ha demostrado
que es el mejor lugar para investigar.
La pregunta ahora es ¿De verdad es el mejor
lugar para aprender?
Es decir ¿Seguirá siendo tan importante
tener un título universitario para conseguir
un buen trabajo en el futuro?
Esto es tema para otro vídeo.
Pero este va a ser un debate que dará mucho
de que hablar en los propios años.
Atentos a esta noticia.
Google, Apple y otras 12 empresas que ya no
piden a sus empleados un título universitario
Así que ahora es turno para ti ¿Crees que
el modelo universitario va a cambiar?
¿Crees que nuestros hijos tendrán que endeudarse
para pagar su universidad... o tal vez terminen
sacándose un título de Google?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a VisualPolitik y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.